go back with Oprah and the real reason
she came to the broadcast this morning
her highly anticipated book club
selection only on CBS this morning
Oprah drum roll please American dirt
American dirt American dirt by Janine
Cummings yes I love it so much why well
first of all from Janine coming for the
very first sentence the one of the very
first bullets comes in through the open
window above the toilet where Luca is
standing I was in I was in from the very
first sentence we should say this book
is receiving critical acclaim for its
powerful portrayal of a migrants journey
across the border to the US it focuses
on the story of Lydia a mother who
escapes from Mexico with her son after
surviving a brutal attack by a drug
cartel Jeanine Cummings is also with us
welcome thanks for being here thank you
for having a son no guys her son yes
years old
mm-hmm what was the moment like when you
got a phone call from Oprah's Oh best
moment of my life for the four words
every writer dreams of hearing Jeanine
it's Oprah Winfrey and I was very
jet-lagged I had just gotten off a plane
from the UK and I think I said very
early in the conversation this is not
Oprah Winfrey right now and she said yes
it is it's Oprah I used to say we'll be
right back as you know that you know you
birthday surprise surprise Janeane this
is so fascinating to me about the book
because already there are little you
have a little bit of Gatorade against
you people are drinking it about you and
you said even you were first worried
then you had no business writing this
book you felt compelled yet unqualified
right yeah well you know it's a migrant
story it is a migrant story in Mexico I
always knew that I wanted to write about
immigration I was interested in that
topic and I I wasn't I resisted for a
very long time telling the story from a
migrants point of view because I was
worried that I but I didn't know enough
that my privilege would make me blind to
certain truths what convinced you that
you
that you could write it I mean look I
felt very compelled and it was five
years of research and two failed drafts
that convinced me that I needed to go
into Lydia's point of view and there was
a point very early on in that research
where I was speaking with a very
generous scholar a woman who was chair
of the Chicano Studies department at San
Diego State University at the time and
she said to me I expressed my concerns
about this and she said Ginny and we
need every voice we can get telling this
story
what touch do you Oprah Beth what touch
me into the writing first of all the
language is the first thing that pulls
being in any story and then what touch
me is by the end of the story not even
by the end I immediately was drawn into
the story and their their desire to get
to the United States and every night on
the news I think you hear so many
stories you hear so many migrants
stories because I watched Norah
O'Donnell every evening you see the
stories at the border I thought this
humanized that migration process in a
way that nothing else I had ever felt or
seen had and I agree with you this is
one story and I'm saying let everybody
else tell your story but this story
really changed me and changed the way I
see what it means to be an immigrant
trying to come to this country and you
started focusing on it before it was
even that even before it was in the
zeitgeist this conversation about the
migrants and the border wall yeah 2013 I
started writing I started researching
and you know I went to the borderlands I
went I spent time on both sides of the
border I went to Casa Amiga Dante I
visited migrant shelters I volunteered
at at this ini daughter which is a soup
kitchen and it's the most powerful part
of all of that for you I think you know
I met so many migrants and listening to
their stories and also the people who
are doing the work to support migrants
and put themselves bodily in harm's way
to be a protection for people who are so
vulnerable seeing the you know the the
enormous amounts of hope and real
courage like what actual bravery looks
like
made me so guys we're gonna go to the
border to do the book club and film it
for appletv plus Wow that's where we're
gonna do the actual location yes we say
all the places are real you're gonna go
there yeah we're gonna go we're gonna go
where people cross over to the border
and we're gonna film there forever gets
to go people who are writing to at
Oprah's Book Club come Oprah
Janine Cummins thank you so much for
being with us American dirt now on sale
now and you can read an excerpt on
Oprah's new book subselection on our
website CBS this morning calm
you